Android - Performance Patterns
Sometimes it's not the big,
glaring performance problems that get you,
it's the little insignificant cost
of small functions,
executed over and over again
that add up to big problems.
I'm Joanna Smith and rather than suffering
the death of a thousand cuts,
you can utilize batching
to keep your app alive.
Almost everything in computing
has some associated performance overhead
that goes along with it.
This could be something big,
like decompressing an image,
which requires a lot of memory allocations
to store the intermediate data.
Or it can be something small,
like the extra memory copies
and pointer management that tag
along with recursive functions.
Now typically, these perf taxes
aren't much of a concern.
But when executed multiple times, where
multiple is some seriously big number,
this overhead can become a serious
performance burden for your application.
And this is where batching comes in handy.
Batching is the process
of grouping together
identical instances of a task.
This way the associated overhead
happens once, not once per instance.
For example, if you're going to
render the same image 20 times,
try loading it once before you begin
instead of loading it for every render.
After all, nesting your computations
together gets you more bang for the buck.
For Android, one of the most important
places you can leverage batching
is with networking requests.
Basically, there's an overhead cost
each time you need to turn on
your phone's cell radio.
So, if you're sending a packet out
once every 30 seconds,
you're paying for that cost every packet.
Instead, you should group one
to two minutes worth of requests together,
turn the radio on once and send all
of those requests at the same time.
But batching is pretty helpful
in other situations too,
like rendering custom views.
Rather than computing a transform matrix
for every item, you could group them and
make small changes to a larger transform
matrix, saving you precious resources.
And then there's the most obvious case
for batching, where some function
needs to compute a lookup table
before working on the data.
So, making a version that can
batch together 20 pieces of data
for one lookup table creation
is a clear batching win.
In fact, batching is so important
that all modern processors now
come equipped with mathematical
batching support.
Single instruction multiple data functions
allow you to execute
the same mathematical functions on
multiple pieces of data all in parallel.
So, instead of spending
individual CPU cycles
on each of the four pieces of
data, you can spend one cycle
and get the same results.
And that's really what the
core of performance is about.
Finding every opportunity to reduce
even the slightest performance overhead.
Because a one millisecond overhead
called 16 times in one frame
is all it takes to destroy
your frame rate.
So, to see other improvements
and find more perf advice,
check out the rest of our
Android Performance Patterns content.
And consider joining our G+ Community
for tips, tricks, and help.
But most importantly, keep calm,
profile your code,
and always remember,
perf matters!
(music playing)